the restaurant osterley de la baie de la
salle is located in the park of the 12th
century Benedictine abbey it's a place
to relax and forget time the building's
thick walls block out the noise from the
street
the restaurant serves specialties from
Provence chef Benoit Fitz's cuisine
takes its cue from the medieval
surroundings of their history lock
additional isn't a DS it was traditional
for the monks or nuns to produce
everything themselves on site including
foodstuffs you know and we try to follow
this tradition by using as many locally
grown or regional products as possible
it is you know the booze [ __ ]
early in the morning Benoit vets
harvests fresh herbs from the abbeys
garden today he plucks mint basil lemon
balm and parsley he'll use them later in
a pesto served with the PAS visage
spring vegetables he'll create for
euromaxx
till I'm not your nature determines what
I'll do today we see that the zucchini
and peas look fantastic so we'll take
the zucchini with us as long as it still
has this slender shape that I love I
don't come to the garden with plans but
let what I find here surprise me but did
prove it the chef harvests vegetables
only when they're fully ripe this time
that means fennel zucchini onions green
beans and peas
he'll use them in the kitchen
immediately cover you deported the most
important thing is to deal with the
products as simply and naturally as
possible so that their intrinsic flavors
come to the fore first the different
sorts of vegetables are cut into pieces
of about the same size
then they're placed in these round
bodied ceramic pots
consider a loofah to preserve the
original flavor we use a shallow round
pot that conserves the liquid Kiba if we
were to cook the vegetables in water it
would lose its vitamins and flavors Lulu
but this spot cooks the vegetables in
their own juice and that preserves all
the natural aroma the vegetables are
cooked with only a dash of olive oil
first Benoit sautes the onions and the
fennel
then he adds the zucchini and beans then
finally the peas total cooking time is
10 minutes meanwhile Benoit vitz
prepares a pesto from herbs olive oil
and garlic
2 p's up waseem along with the herbs you
can also use leaves from various kinds
of vegetables and stare at all until you
get a green puree and that gives a dish
a special flavor okay that's what you
see are an exhaustible the finish spring
vegetables are garnished with zucchini
blossoms and the pesto
then they're served directly in the
ceramic pot it retains heat so that even
outdoors the vegetables don't cool off
so fast diners can take their time over
their meal
love with you see larva vivo the French
art of living means experiencing a
moment of total relaxation surrounded by
walls steeped in history yo Shawn you
hear the cicadas singing you have good
food on your plate and drink a glass of
rosé say if that's the charm of Provence
hasta la de la baie de la salle is the
kind of place where you can escape the
hectic pace of everyday life
you